vendredi 5 octobre La Grande Sophie se
produira sur la scène du scarabée à la
verrière et justement nous sommes avec
vous bonsoir bonsoir alors j'invite vous
demander pourquoi la Grande Sophie vous
êtes grande ça c'est vrai mais est-ce
que c'est la seule raison vous avez
donné la réponse voilà
tout le monde vous le disait ça vous
êtes grande oui c'est vrai que c'est ce
qui a fait que je
me reconnaisse en tout cas à travers ce
pseudonyme et puis je trouvais ça très
imagé et
j'ai gardé tout de suite alors vous
allez nous présenter ce nouvel album
j'imagine sur scène dans votre nouvelle
tournée il y aura aussi des anciens
titres on retrouvera les titres qu'on a
connu avec vous oui j'adore justement
quand je pars en tournée c'est réarrangé
les anciens titres leur donner de
nouveaux costumes et les mettre au goût
de la nouvelle tournée donc là je laisse
la surprise au public de venir découvrir
justement les titres qui connaissent
déjà alors quels sont pour les titres
qu'ils ne connaissent pas ce que vous
avez peut-être choisi pas tout révéler
mais en donner au moins quelques-uns
pour ce concert
je vais chanter en majorité le dernier
album la place du fantôme je vais leur
présenter et puis et puis mais je n'aime
pas trop raconter ce qui va se passer
puisque justement un concert c'est
amener le public dans un climat une
atmosphère très particulière et je
préfère leur laisser découvrir tout ça
alors on sait que vous partez souvent
tourné avec des musiciens obsols on sait
que vous partez avec votre guitare et
votre et votre grosse caisse alors là on
la retrouve ici sur sur la scène mais
qu'est-ce que vous préférez vous plutôt
être solitaire ou entouré sont deux
plaisirs très différents et je en tout
cas que ce soit dans des petites sales
ou des festivals les plus grandes salles
je j'aime trouver mes repères pour pour
qu'il y ait un contact avec le public
c'est ce qui compte cet échange là et
chaque soir je me débrouille pour aller
le retrouver pour même descendre dans la
salle j'ai besoin de de proximité avec
le public oui j'aime ça ne m'oublie pas
c'est votre chanson phare quelle est
l'histoire de cette de cette chanson
on retombe dans un de mes thèmes
récurrent qui est le temps qui passe
c'est une façon d'en parler mais une
façon très différente que ce que j'ai pu
aborder auparavant donc ça a un rapport
avec le temps oui vous vous considérez
plus comme une musicienne une écrivaine
parce que vous composez aussi les
paroles ou une interprète que vous vous
touchez à tout
est-ce que vous avez une préférence ou
est-ce que vous préféreriez que vous
définissent plus musicienne que
qu'interprètes ou quand j'écris une
chanson j'aime de moments en particulier
la fin
quand j'ai construit vraiment la chanson
quand elle est terminée ça c'est un de
mes plaisirs de savoir qu'elle est
aboutie et que c'est ce que je voulais
et ensuite c'est c'est d'aller la
chanter devant un public ça c'est une
excitation
supplémentaire que j'aime beaucoup aussi
alors la prochaine date donc la verrière
vous serez également dans une salle
parisienne très bientôt en novembre oui
le 23 novembre je serai à l'Olympia vous
avez hâte oui c'est vraiment une salle
remplie de fantômes justement alors
juste une dernière question si on
pouvait vous comparer à une artiste ou
un artiste contemporain lequel vous
choisiriez
mais justement moi si je fais des
chansons si j'écris des chansons c'est
pour être
c'est pour être moi avant tout donc
c'est être comparé
je sais que souvent on veut vous
comparer mais je préfère
j'essaie de montrer qui je suis et
d'être le plus juste possible